vous savez qu'ils sont nombreux les 5
fois 20 ans en limousin nous avons
l'occasion de vous en parler de temps à
autre sur cette antenne il habite par
exemple saint julien le vendômois la
villetelle saint junien chéronnac mas
bajo meyrignat ou encore limoges pour ce
noël 80 nous avons voulu vous en faire
connaître 3 marie-mai zone yo 105 ans
sans doute la doyenne des limousins anna
de laurent 100 ans
sentant le mois dernier elle n'a rien
perdu de sa mémoire vous allez le
constater et jean cani 104 ans doyen des
limousins l'échangé de village j'ai
habité à suivre les abords et puis ce
n'est mais j'ai rien et qui tire la
commune les pays et mouvements
comment est ce que vous vous occupiez
autrefois un gîte et cultivateurs de
soigner les bêches je faisais venir
doubler le prix protégeant les échos
selon robbie rivera chine et et je suis
resté limité de monsieur vous sauver la
vie sony 63 slr de la campagne du koala
qui vous a conservé comme ça où les rues
est ce que vous avez eu un régime
particulier vous levier de bonheur sans
doute comment vous vous leviez de
bonheur aux matin le mandat je les ai
achetés de bonne heure et le soir je ne
les ai pas beaucoup étaient fatigués
vous aimez bien recevoir la visite de
votre famille oh oui je suis content
s'il tous les hommes les hommes je
comprends très bien ce qu'ils disent
comprenez les femmes ne parlent pas
assez fort mais elle parle bien c'est
fort mais elle se dépêche trop vite la
dépendance trop vite et bien je ne
comprends pas bien vous avez combien de
petits enfants arrière petits enfants
derrière dix enfants et j'en ai attendez
jamais 3 2 qui sont angoulême de cuisson
à limoges ça fait ça non comment passer
ton noël
autrefois ça faisait la veille d'un
grand raid en jeu
de plus ce jeu où l'on payé entre les
fleuves dans une toile on est vrai dire
on les bus et on les mange les et après
quand on avait mangé ça il ya des
endroits que soient les lys avancée mais
moi je ne sais pas on faisait le
réveillon on faisait des vidéos et la
messe de minuit
est-ce qu'elle était très fréquenté oh
oui elles étaient comptés regardez
beaucoup de monde au centre gényer
qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui ils
reconnaissent que la ville tandis qu'à
la campagne il ya rien de plus
comme on mange et on décrète il y avait
quelques bonbons déploie quelques
noisettes quelques plats line pas
toujours vous mangez vous manger comme
autrefois là vous avez le même appétit
ben je mange assez bien n'est pas
beaucoup
tout ce que j'ai que j'ai je vois très
souvent je vois beaucoup je bois
beaucoup il ne propose autour parce que
j'ai peur qu'on me dise que je me suis
soudé et nous a coûté un doute mais je
veux boire souvent et pas beaucoup à
l'emploi qu'est ce que vous buvez
dizaine en creuse sur la commune de mas
bajo meyrignat voici marie-mai zone yo
105 ans
c'est lucette son arrière petite fille
qui l'interrogent pour nous les zones
indique à quel âge tu as commencé à
travailler à bien j'ai quatre tailles
étaient tellement belle et elle est
belle mais c'est mérité
janet véritable culte et des moutons
plus tôt on tu t'occupais des moutons tu
as de garder
je m'occupais de tout commence passer
noël quand tu étais jeune vous alliez à
la messe à la messe de minuit
ah oui je ce soit des lois oui elle
s'est taillé la velléité complet de
demande tu es allé avec tes parents avec
tes frères est-ce que tu recevais des
cadeaux à noël pratique d'un certain
tony tan est bien ça vous est bien
arrivé de tuer le cochon à noël mais mon
petit dalston des malades et ya pas de
caution au mais ça arrive et vient entre
temps il avait pu être habillé il
n'avait pas tellement des maisons oui
ils n'avaient pas du coach alors qu'est
ce que vous faisiez du fromage vous
mangé de fromages
elle est à l'hommage est bien c'est
qu'on l'avait madame de laurent vous
êtes donc centenaire depuis cette année
vous avez été fêté une belle cérémonie
oui très belle j'ai beaucoup de monde de
venir vous avez beaucoup d'amis oui je
ne vois que des jamais je le veux je me
vois pas d'animer vous avez eu un fils
qui était très connu qui était prêtre
qui était pas de chaîne pierre et à aix
et atx mais il était à et chavannes
venir à saint pierre
vous vous lever à quelle heure le matin
au 8ème et autrefois vous levier de
bonheur au jeu me lever à 4 heures du
matin en fait votre gros travail c'était
de vous occuper de vos enfants
oui mon âge il n'a jamais voulu cacher
un atelier moi j'aurais voulu y aller
parce que je ne travaillais pas
seulement il ne voulait pas que je
laisse la porte fermée quand mes enfants
revenu de l'école et pour les
chaufferies moi alors je n'ai pas pu
aller à la télé je me tais et embaucher
une fois dans un petit à petit il n'est
pas venu chez nous si faisait des
cartons
alassane est pas difficile j'avais vu ça
sur le journal puis je m'étais présentes
à cette maison alors monsieur m'a dit
que je commence lundi à travailler dans
ce magasin alors je suis parti je
n'avais rien dit à mon mari parce que je
savais qu'ils ne veulent pas que je m'en
aille
là je lui ai dit ah il m'a dit tu n'as
pas eu cette idée plutôt c'est jamal
j'ai eu a dit eh bien voyez les femmes
au travail voyez ça existait déjà de
votre temps un oui est aujourd'hui aussi
vous savez les femmes veulent travailler
elles veulent plus rester à la maison
ben oui moi j'avais voulu faire comme
elle parce que mes voisines tu allais à
la télé à loches qui par lequel je
faisais des journées portable impliqué
très bien est ce que vous pensiez un
jour que vous iriez jusqu'à son temps au
nom au nom même les voisines me dit avec
la vie qui l amène elle ne viendra pas
vieille alors comment est ce que vous
avez pu vivre jusqu'à 100 ans un régime
particulier beaucoup de noms alors
maintenant madame de laurent on va
parler de noël puisque c'est la période
de noël
nous allons demander à marie laure de
vous poser une première question
autrefois ce que les gens là la messe de
minuit est ce que j'ai apporté des
cadeaux l'enfant jésus à brion la portée
des orages des formes de pommiers quel
est le plus beau souvenir que vous avez
de noël comme cadeau la veille une
petite boîte de bonbons avec une praline
un fan d'ann et des dragées lé terrain
quand tout est votre meilleur noël votre
meilleur souvenir de noël venir à
feytiat peut-être en aller à feytiat
on y aller avec des torches de paille
que tu les meubles tous les voisins de
à peine le pays tient là des environs de
crise indépendante et de tous ses
environs on allait de plans toutes les
communes on avait des tas de paille
qu'on a lui même montré notre chemin
on se réunissait tous à la station de la
sainte vierge où le curé venu nous
chercher
au premier coup de la cloche avec eux
les enfants de choeur et nous ramener à
l'église et puis on attendait la messe
de minuit
comment se passer noël après la messe de
minuit et bien sache pas c'est qu'on
allait voir le bain chaud dans un
restaurant qu'il y avait sur la place le
pays tient et puis on manger des
brioches madame d'oloron est ce que les
sapins de noël existait déjà
oui est-ce qu'on passait beaucoup noël
en famille
on passait beaucoup de noël en famille
j'avais mes grands parents comme mon
père allait chercher à l'image qui
passer noël avec nous les voisins
venaient appelait ont passé toute la
nuit éveillés à un champ en chantant des
cantiques de noël
il est né le 19 ans chantant tous
n'avaient de mam ah qu'il est beau qu'il
est charmant
[Musique]